the US economy lost more than 20 point
five million jobs in April and one point
four million of them were in health care
a sector that has historically been
recession-proof
this chart shows employment numbers
between 1990 and 2020 this downturn is
the Great Recession when millions of
workers were laid off you can see health
care jobs continue to rise during that
same period and the same can be seen
during other recessions too but this
time it's different an experts say that
the impact from the coronavirus crisis
could fundamentally change the
healthcare sector and a lot of the jobs
lost and not likely to return health
care has been among the most resilient
industries in the economy and they're
really two reasons for this David Cutler
is an economics professor at Harvard and
has done a lot of work understanding how
the medical system operates and how it
responds to events like kovat 19 when is
because people have insurance and second
is because people's illness tends not to
vary too much over expansions and
recessions since the pandemic anything
that's not emergency people have cut
enormous lis and even many emergencies
use of care for emergencies is way way
down to help the SEC to cope with the
virus some healthcare restrictions were
relaxed as part of the eight point three
billion dollar coronavirus stimulus
package that gave a big boost for
different parts of the healthcare
industry including telemedicine that saw
one company report a 50 percent rise in
tellement services now people both in
private insurance and in medicare are
using telemedicine a lot it's hoped that
that can then become a usual part of
practice on a scope of practice front we
enabled a lot of nurse practitioners
medical assistants physician's
assistants to do more now that we've
done that we want to be able to keep
that and the third one which is really
important is most physicians practices
and hospitals get their money by doing
more services when people don't go to
the doctor the providers
lose money a way out of that is to pay
on a fixed say per patient per month
basis and so that's another change
people would like to see become a
permanent change
another reason a rebound in healthcare
will be harder than previous years is
people's financial exposure to
healthcare just looking at the last
recession and the out-of-pocket expenses
were far less than what they are today
if you're in a big recession and you now
learn that you're gonna pay twenty five
hundred dollars out of pocket before
insurance pays anything people may
decide they're happier cutting back
particularly since they just had
experienced cutting back during the
first phase of the COBIT epidemic if you
then add on top of that what the
potential for for example coated to come
back in the late summer or fall and by
that point you really have people with a
very different outlook for what they
want in the medical system providers in
very different shape and people with in
a financial situation where they may not
want to go back to the care they were
receiving health care in the u.s.
continues to be one of the most debated
issues among lawmakers and politicians
and on a global level the u.s. spends at
least 17 percent of GDP on health care
whereas most other developed countries
spend a fifty percent less on average so
while it is critical for the US economy
that health care rebounds and that it
continues to provide care for those who
regularly need it economists are
watching for signs that it emerges from
the pandemic more streamlined so it's
really a very bad idea to have a health
care system that's bloated they pay a
lot and they don't get what they need
now the best way to deal with this is
not to just shut everything off at once
and lay off a ton of people but to
gradually do things so that you make
that change so what I would hope is that
after we make it through the first part
of the epidemic phase we come back in a
way that's more streamlined so that
healthcare isn't as expensive and then
we help those people who are not
bringing back to find other really
productive things they can do as well
you